David the more I see the left get
involved in these cultural issues like
cancel culture and wokeness the more I
think the left should just not even
bother to fight those issues what do you
think this is a very interesting
question
um we see that right now there's a
really big divide between the Democratic
and Republican Party in the sense that
the Democratic party is almost
exclusively about legislation and issues
and the Republican party is not and
earlier this week I argued with
Republican strategist Amanda Mackey
about it who I still don't even know
exactly what point she was trying to
make but needless to say her argument is
well now Republicans can't do policy
because they don't control anything well
but they didn't do any policy during the
Trump era either
um as a result the right is just
fighting cultural issues they're talking
about uh cancel culture they're talking
about
um
uh control you know transports control
of uh the narrative by the left wokeness
and all of this different stuff uh I
don't believe that the left should give
up those issues but I do think that it
would be best for the the left to
realize that just because an issue is
getting a lot of traction on Twitter and
Fox News doesn't mean it's actually an
issue that much of the democratic
electorate cares about and you need to
look only at the 2020 Democratic primary
to understand that and I know this is
painful for many in my audience to hear
I wish it were different but there were
a lot of people millions of people on
the left
who spend a lot of time on Twitter and
Reddit and saw the enthusiasm for Bernie
Sanders at rallies and wrongly believed
that the Bernie wing of the democratic
electorate was is bigger than it
actually is it doesn't mean it's
insignificant it doesn't mean it doesn't
matter it doesn't mean that that it's
not a wing with good ideas it is but the
2020 Democratic primary reminded us when
it wasn't even close I mean Joe Biden
really won very easily by millions of
votes even before it was you know
everybody bailed and all that all that
stuff
um what you see on Reddit and Twitter
and on Newsmax or Fox News it's not what
the bulk of the country actually cares
about and similarly for me it's not
about the left
conceding or giving up on the cultural
issues it's understanding that most
Americans are not focused in on trans
Sports wokeness doc Dr Seuss or cancel
culture they're just not first of all
tons of Americans don't even pay
attention to news in the way that you
and I do
and of those that do we know the issues
that are most important it's in no
particular order the economy jobs wages
Health Care coronavirus pandemic
recovery those those are the issues
those are the primary issues so once you
understand that and then you realize
that very little of these culture wars
involve actual policy makers in policy
positions this is an important
distinction yes Congressman Jim Jordan
Will Go On Laura Ingram's show and talk
about the cancel culture Laura you know
we he does that Matt Gates when he's
trying to distract from you know
investigations into child sex
trafficking he will talk about cancel
culture Trump talked I get it you see
people like you know Marjorie Taylor
green or whatever try to bring some of
this stuff to the house floor Jim Jordan
says you need an investigation into Dr
Seuss for the most part very little of
this culture War stuff is even touching
real policy making legislative uh uh
time at the state level uh and at the
national level it's Amplified by
conservatives a few of them it's
Amplified by the Internet it's Amplified
by some right-wing media so the way I
would say it is Democrats don't need to
just concede a loss on cultural issues
Democrats don't need to not bother
fighting on cultural issues Democrats
just need to recognize that the culture
war is a distraction that Republicans
have chosen to take on because they have
no policy ideas other than prevent
Democrats from doing anything
and they have nothing to actually bring
to the table at this point in time
one last thought on this
eventually
Democrats tend to be Vindicated on most
of these cultural issues I mean look at
abortion okay it took what 40 50 years
abortion being legal in most cases is
more popular now than at any point since
Roe v Wade
it took a while but the culture shifted
and caught up with where quote the left
has been
gay marriage most people in the U.S
including more than 50 percent of
Republicans now believe
gay marriage should just be legal it's
been legal since 2015. Democrats the
left have been fighting for that for
much longer eventually the culture came
around marijuana approval death penalty
not being you you get it right so
another reason not to engage in the way
that the right wants to is that
eventually the country tends to come
around now you don't want to ignore
serious issues like death penalty
marijuana Etc
all together because if you do then
nobody's advocating for your side but
the cancel culture thing is different
and I do think that democrats should
just understand that this is not a big
issue to most Americans period
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com Pacman I've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like I said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com Pacman